This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In high school, Naomi Rothman was a shy teenager. That is, until she laced up her cleats and stepped on the field for her travel soccer team. Surrounded by teammates she loved, Naomi became a completely different person. We were called the Red Hot Chili Peppers and it was very meaningful to me because I created these really strong friendships and it gave me a lot of confidence. It gave me a sense of self-worth and self-esteem and I really strongly identified with this team. There was just one catch. The players on this team predominantly came from the east side of town and played at Harbor High.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦姆。在高中时，娜奥米·罗斯曼是一个害羞的青少年。直到她穿上钉鞋，为她的旅游足球队踏上球场。在一群她深爱的队友身边，娜奥米变成了一个完全不同的人。我们被称为“红辣椒”乐队，这对我意义重大，因为我结下了非常深厚的友谊，这给了我很大的自信。它给了我自尊和自我价值感，我非常强烈地认同这支球队。这里只有一个问题。这支球队的队员主要来自城东，并在港湾高中踢球。
Naomi's school, Santa Cruz High, was on the west side of our hometown of Santa Cruz, California. And so during our high school season, we had to play against each other, and someone always had to lose. Harbor and Santa Cruz were always among the top contenders. The rivalry between the schools was intense. Every game we played against one another was high stakes, and these games were some of the most emotionally fraught games that I ever played. And the reason was that I loved these players. I had this deep, genuine affection for the people that I was played. And the reason was that I loved these players. I had this deep, genuine affection
娜奥米的学校圣克鲁斯高中，位于我们家乡加利福尼亚州圣克鲁斯的西侧。因此在我们高中的赛季里，我们不得不互相比赛，而且总得有人输球。港湾高中和圣克鲁斯高中一直是顶级竞争者。学校之间的竞争非常激烈。我们彼此进行的每一场比赛都事关重大，这些比赛是我打过的情绪最激动的比赛之一。原因是我爱这些球员。我对和我一起比赛的人有着这种深厚而真挚的情感。原因是我爱这些球员。我对这些人有着深厚而真挚的情感
for the people that I was trying to beat. The same player she had fought alongside as a member of the Red Hot Chili Peppers were now trying to crush her when Harbor High faced Santa Cruz. Her friends had become her frenemies. Her friends had become her frenemies. Naomi Rothman never forgot what that early experience felt like. Today, she's a psychologist who studies what happens to our minds
我试图击败的人。曾经作为“红辣椒”队员与她并肩作战的同一名球员，现在当港湾高中对阵圣克鲁斯时，却试图击碎她。她的朋友们已经变成了她的亦敌亦友。她的朋友们已经变成了她的亦敌亦友。娜奥米·罗斯曼永远不会忘记早年那种感觉是什么样的。今天，她是一位心理学家，研究当我们的心灵发生时会发生什么
when we feel like we are being emotionally pulled in opposite directions. It's absolutely an uncomfortable state. In fact, that will then kind of set the stage for how you engage with your environment, which is essentially to try to get rid of that feeling of discomfort. The pain, paralysis and promise of mixed emotions. this week on Hidden Brain. Sometimes we feel just one single feeling with overwhelming force. We are joyously happy. We are crushingly sad. But sometimes it's more complicated than that.
当我们感到自己在情感上被拉向相反的方向时。这绝对是一种不舒服的状态。事实上，这会为你的环境互动方式奠定基础，其本质就是试图摆脱那种不适感。复杂情感的痛苦、瘫痪与希望。本周的《隐藏的大脑》。有时我们会以压倒性的力量感受到单一的感觉。我们欣喜若狂。我们痛不欲生。但有时事情比这更复杂。
We feel happy and sad at the same time. At Lehigh University, psychologist Naomi Rothman studies the mixed emotion of ambivalence. She explores how ambivalence changes the way we think and how it changes the way others see us. Naomi Rothman, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me here with you. Naomi, you have a young daughter, and she recently told you she wanted a hot new toy called a Magic Mixies Cauldron.
我们同时感到快乐和悲伤。在理海大学，心理学家娜奥米·罗斯曼研究了矛盾心理这种复杂的情感。她探讨了矛盾心理如何改变我们的思维方式，以及它如何改变其他人对我们的看法。娜奥米·罗斯曼，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我来这里和你一起。娜奥米，你有一个小女儿，她最近告诉你她想要一个叫做“魔法密西斯大锅”的热门新玩具。
What is a Magic Mixies Cauldron, and what was your reaction to her request? Apparently, this is a toy where there's a special wand that allows you to mix a potion, and it creates a mist to rise. And this cute little furry friend, called a Magic Mixie, appears through the mist. And all she really wants is this toy. And all of her friends are obsessed with this toy.
什么是“魔法密西斯大锅”，你对她的要求有什么反应？显然，这是一个玩具，里面有一根特殊的魔杖，可以让你混合药水，它会产生上升的雾气。这个被称为“魔法密西斯”的可爱小毛茸茸的朋友，透过雾气出现了。她真正想要的只有这个玩具。她所有的朋友都对这个玩具着迷。
It's kind of constantly on their minds. And when I looked up online, kind of the reviews, which is what I always typically do, I was completely ambivalent. There are all these complaints that the potion leaks, that it stains your rug, it's a total waste of money, and it's like this one and done activity. Naomi had mixed feelings about getting the toy, but then she started hearing from other
它们似乎一直在他们脑海里。当我在网上查找评论时，正如我通常所做的那样，我完全持矛盾态度。有各种各样的抱怨说药水会漏，会弄脏你的地毯，这完全是在浪费钱，而且就像是一次性活动。娜奥米对得到这个玩具感到心情复杂，但随后她开始听到其他
moms. They were going to great lengths to get it during a time of limited inventory. I actually had a friend who texted me that she was at Target waiting for the shipment to be unboxed because she was told that they might actually have a delivery of a few of these. And this is a working mother who's basically hanging out at Target to get one of these cauldrons. She's not ambivalent at all, right? She's completely committed. I ultimately decided to go ahead and get it,
妈妈们的意见。在库存有限的时候，她们不惜一切代价去买。实际上我有一个朋友发信息给我，说她在塔吉特等待开箱发货，因为她被告知他们可能真的会运来几个这样的东西。这是一个基本上在塔吉特闲逛以买到其中一个大锅的职场母亲。她一点也不矛盾，对吧？她完全投入了。我最终决定去买它，
but that was after a whole lot of vacillation. And lo and behold, by the time I actually pulled the trigger, the prices had skyrocketed and it's totally sold out at all of our local Target stores. And my lack of action is going to cost me either time I'm going to have to go hang out in Target for the next shipment, it's going to cost me in terms of money, or it's going to cost me in terms of my daughter's happiness.
但那是经过了大量的犹豫不决之后。而看吧，等我真正下定决心的时候，价格已经飙升，我们当地所有的塔吉特商店都完全卖光了。我的不作为将使我付出代价：要么我要花时间在下一次发货时去塔吉特闲逛，要么我要在金钱上付出代价，或者我要以我女儿的幸福为代价付出代价。
of my daughter's happiness. I want to look at another moment in your life, perhaps with slightly more serious stakes, where you also felt ambivalence. You were working on a project with several other colleagues when you experienced a rather severe bout of ambivalence. What happened and how did your colleagues receive your ambivalence? I had this really great opportunity to convene a group of world-class academics to work on a project on ambivalence. And this was a really big deal for me because I'm bringing together experts in different areas of research who, you know, as coming up as an academic, you look up to other scholars, right? These like older academic brothers and sisters or aunts and uncles, whatever you wanna call them.
我女儿的幸福。我想看看你生活中的另一个时刻，也许有着稍微严肃一点的赌注，你也在其中感到了矛盾心理。你当时正和几个同事合作一个项目，经历了一次相当严重的矛盾心理发作。发生了什么，你的同事们是如何看待你的矛盾心理的？我有一个非常棒的机会，召集了一群世界级的学者来做一个关于矛盾心理的项目。这对我很重要，因为我把不同研究领域的专家聚集在一起，你知道的，作为一个刚崭露头角的学者，你会仰慕其他学者，对吧？这些年长的学术兄弟姐妹或叔叔阿姨，无论你怎么称呼他们。
And here I got to work with them on my area of expertise. They were giving me a seat at their table and I was an expert. So everything starts off great, it's really generative, I feel really good about what's going on. But then it starts to take a little bit of a turn because we're going into areas that I know more about than they do. And I realize this.
在这里，我有机会与他们合作我的专业领域。他们给了我一张桌子旁的座位，而我是一位专家。所以一切都有了一个美好的开始，真的很有建设性，我对正在发生的事情感觉非常好。但随后事情开始发生了一点转变，因为我们进入的领域是我比他们更了解的。我意识到了这一点。
And so there's this pressure because on the one hand, I feel in some ways subordinate to them. But on the other hand, this is my meeting, right? And what happens when the conversation starts to veer is that I feel like I have three options, right? On one hand, I have this choice, I can remain silent. But a second choice is to play the cheerleader, right? Hey, guys, this is great.
所以有一种压力，因为一方面，我在某种程度上觉得从属于他们。但另一方面，这是我的会议，对吧？当对话开始偏离时，我觉得我有三个选择，对吧？一方面，我有这个选择，我可以保持沉默。但第二个选择是扮演啦啦队长，对吧？嘿，伙计们，这太棒了。
Keep it going. No wrong answers here. And I felt like a third option is to tell them what I really thought, which was complex. And it's essentially like showing my ambivalence because my sentiments at the time were very positive and negative, right? And so I was thinking to myself, ultimately, this is a conversation about ambivalence, and so ambivalence should be honored here. And I didn't want to miss out on this opportunity to create something great
继续保持。这里没有错误的答案。我觉得第三个选择是告诉他们我真正的想法，这是复杂的。这本质上就像是展现我的矛盾心理，因为我当时的感受非常积极和消极，对吧？所以我心里在想，归根结底，这是一场关于矛盾心理的对话，所以矛盾心理在这里应该受到尊重。我不想错过这个创造伟大成果的机会
with these really esteemed scholars. Naomi tentatively entered the discussion. Instead of cheerleading or criticizing, she hesitantly expressed her mixed feelings. The intervention backfired. The unintended consequences of showing my ambivalence in this meeting is that it indicated my indecision, it indicated a lack of assertiveness or dominance, and it actually invited others in this meeting to take charge
与这些备受尊敬的学者们。娜奥米试探性地加入了讨论。她没有加油鼓劲或批评，而是犹豫不决地表达了她复杂的心情。这种干预适得其反。在这场会议中表现出我的矛盾心理所产生的意料之外的后果是，它表明了我的优柔寡断，表明我缺乏自信或支配欲，并且实际上邀请了会议中的其他人来掌控
of the conversation. But this was supposed to be my party. This was supposed to be my meeting. And that was kind of a difficult outcome to stomach. And in some ways, this matches what you have found in some of your research when people view others who express ambivalence, they actually look down on them or potentially even want to take advantage of them. Yeah.
对话。但这本该是我的派对。这本该是我的会议。这是一个很难咽下的苦果。在某种程度上，这与你在一些研究中发现的一致：当人们看待表达矛盾心理的人时，他们实际上会看不起他们，甚至可能想利用他们。是的。
So in the first few studies for my dissertation, I showed that people tend to have negative perceptions of those who are ambivalent. So those who are expressing that they feel tension and conflict about something, and that's a result of their mixed emotions. People are more likely to see that ambivalent person compared to a happy person, an angry person, a neutral person as less dominant, less confident, and less assertive.
所以在我的博士论文的前几项研究中，我发现人们往往对那些表现出矛盾心理的人有负面的看法。也就是那些表达对某事感到紧张和冲突的人，这是他们复杂情感的结果。与快乐的人、愤怒的人、中立的人相比，人们更有可能认为矛盾的人支配性较小、不够自信、不够坚定。
And what I found in those studies was that the reaction to perceiving an ambivalent person in that way is that they had this intention to take control and they even took more money from the ambivalent partner than they took from the angry and the neutral partner. And I'm thinking this must also be the case when we interact with you know experts of all kinds when I when I go and talk with a doctor for example I expect the doctor to be decisive, to say, you know, here's what's wrong, here's what we should do. And if the doctor expresses ambivalence, I start to question, is this really a good doctor?
我在这些研究中发现，对这种感知矛盾的人的反应是，他们有掌控一切的意图，他们甚至从矛盾的伴侣身上拿走的钱比从愤怒和中立的伴侣身上拿走的还要多。我想当我们与各种专家互动时，这也是必然的，比如当我去看医生时，我期望医生是果断的，会说，你知道，这是哪里出了问题，我们该怎么做。如果医生表现出矛盾心理，我就会开始怀疑，这真的是一个好医生吗？
I think you're really onto something there. And we've collected some data on that very question with Jessica Marsh, who's also at Lehigh University, we showed that when people read a scenario about a physician who was ambivalent, right, they were torn and conflicted. The patients presenting symptoms for both infection A and infection B. That in fact, those physicians were rated as more indecisive, as less well-informed, as lower in job performance, and people were less likely to say that they would follow their advice. And so I think you're right that there's this sense that we consult experts to produce decisions, and if an expert signals their lack of ability to decide, we tend to lose faith in their
我觉得你确实抓住了重点。我们针对这个问题收集了一些数据，合作者是同样在理海大学的杰西卡·马什，我们发现当人们阅读关于一个表现矛盾的医生的情境时，对吧，他们感到纠结和冲突。病人同时表现出感染A和感染B的症状。事实上，这些医生被评为更加优柔寡断、见识较少、工作表现较差，而且人们不太可能说他们会听从他们的建议。所以我觉得你是对的，有一种感觉，我们咨询专家是为了得出决定，如果一个专家暗示他们缺乏决断能力，我们往往会失去对他们
expertise. One of the fascinating studies that you have done looks at the way leaders of companies are judged during earnings calls when they express ambivalence. Can you tell me about this research and what you found, Naomi? We were really interested in what are the implications of a CEO expressing emotional ambivalence in an earnings call, in particular with relation to how the analysts respond to their ambivalence in terms of the way they show skepticism, right?
专业知识的信心。你做过的一项迷人研究着眼于公司高管在财报电话会议上表达矛盾心理时是如何被评判的。你能告诉我这项研究以及你的发现吗，娜奥米？我们对首席执行官在财报电话会议中表达情感矛盾的含义非常感兴趣，特别是与分析师如何就他们表现出的怀疑态度来回应他们的矛盾心理有关，对吧？
And so what we did was we collected data from earnings calls, we coded it using a text analysis software, and lo and behold, what we found is that indeed, leaders who show their ambivalence in earnings calls, CEOs, CFOs, receive more skepticism from the analysts and from the marketplace, and that women, this effect is enhanced for women executives. And so these executives, when they express ambivalence, they invite more harsh questioning. They face what you call a scrutiny penalty. The performance of that company
所以我们做的是收集了财报电话会议的数据，用文本分析软件进行编码，结果不出所料，我们发现确实，在财报电话会议中表现出矛盾心理的领导者——CEO、CFO，会受到分析师和市场的更多怀疑，而且对于女性来说，这种效应对女性高管来说更加强烈。因此，这些高管在表达矛盾心理时，会招致更严厉的质问。他们面临着你所说的审查惩罚。该公司的业绩
is examined and judged more harshly. Exactly. So what is true, of course, in the realm of business is probably triply true in the realm of politics. Politicians certainly are expected to be decisive and confident. People who are presidents or people who are running for president are expected to know precisely what they think on every issue. I want to play you a political attack ad from some years ago that targeted then US Senator John Kerry, who was running for president in 2004. In which direction would John Kerry lead? Kerry voted for
受到更严厉的审查和判断。没错。所以在商业领域是真的，在政治领域可能更是如此三倍。政客们当然被期望是果断和自信的。总统或竞选总统的人被期望对每个问题都有精准的看法。我想放一段几年前的政治攻击广告，针对当时的美国参议员约翰·克里，他在2004年竞选总统。约翰·克里会把我们带向哪个方向？克里投票支持
the Iraq war, opposed it, supported it, and now opposes it again. He bragged about voting for the 87 billion to support our troops before he voted against it. He voted for education reform and now opposes it. He claims he voted against it. He voted for education reform and now opposes it. He claims he's against increasing Medicare premiums, but voted five times to do so. John Kerry, whichever way the wind blows. And I remember this ad from the time it ran back in 2004, Naomi, and I remember it really was a devastating ad
伊拉克战争，反对它，支持它，现在又反对它。他吹嘘在投票反对为我们的军队提供87亿美元的支持之前，曾投票支持它。他投票支持教育改革，现在又反对它。他声称自己投票反对它。他投票支持教育改革，现在又反对它。他声称自己反对提高医疗保险保费，却为此投了五次赞成票。约翰·克里，风往哪吹就倒向哪。我记得2004年这则广告播出时的情景，娜奥米，我记得这确实是一个毁灭性的广告
because it painted John Kerry as someone who really didn't know his own mind, someone who was, you know, wishy-washy, who would basically go whichever way the wind blows. What do you think ads like this say about how we view ambivalent political leaders? Yeah, so I think that that's a wonderful example, right, of how there can be some liabilities for leaders in sharing their ambivalence.
因为它把约翰·克里描绘成一个根本不了解自己想法的人，一个你知道的、优柔寡断的人，基本上风往哪吹就倒向哪。你认为这样的广告说明了我们如何看待矛盾的政治领袖吗？是的，所以我认为这是一个很好的例子，说明领导者在分享他们的矛盾心理时可能会承担一些责任。
Everyone wants a leader to be black and white because otherwise they might look inauthentic if they changed and were inconsistent. And there's evidence that says we would like a dominant leader. We think that they're gonna help us and provide us with certainty about how to act. And it's very interesting to notice
每个人都希望领导者非黑即白，否则如果他们改变且前后不一，他们可能会显得不够真实。有证据表明我们希望有一个占主导地位的领导者。我们认为他们会帮助我们并为我们提供关于如何行动的确定性。非常有趣的是
that that does seem to have emerged as the prototypical model of what it looks like to be a leader. So we've talked about how ambivalence can cause us to miss out on hot Christmas deals or cause our colleagues to get upset with us. We've looked at how we judge leaders poorly if they express ambivalence. Besides all these effects, can we talk a moment about
这似乎已经成为领导者模样的原型模型。所以我们讨论了矛盾心理如何导致我们错过圣诞节的热门优惠，或者导致我们的同事对我们感到不满。我们审视了如果领导者表现出矛盾心理，我们是如何对他们做出糟糕评价的。除了所有这些影响，我们能花一点时间谈谈
the subjective experience of ambivalence? I feel like in my own life when I have felt torn, this is often an unpleasant feeling. I don't necessarily enjoy feeling ambivalent about things. Absolutely. It's considered to be an uncomfortable state. In fact, there's decades of research in the attitude ambivalence literature that draws on dissonance theory, which assumes that when you have an inconsistent state, perhaps like attitude ambivalence, you're going to be feeling pretty uncomfortable,
矛盾心理的主观体验吗？我觉得在我自己的生活中，当我感到纠结时，这通常是一种不愉快的感觉。我对事物感到矛盾不一定觉得享受。绝对是的。这被认为是一种不舒服的状态。事实上，态度矛盾文献中有几十年的研究借鉴了认知失调理论，该理论假设当你处于不一致的状态时，比如态度矛盾，你会感到相当不舒服，
feeling torn and conflicted. And that will then kind of set the stage for how you engage with your environment, which is essentially to try to get rid of that feeling of discomfort. So there's a long history of research that has really established that ambivalence is quite an uncomfortable state.
感到纠结和冲突。然后这就会为你的环境互动方式奠定基础，其本质就是试图摆脱那种不适感。所以有很长的研究历史已经确立了矛盾心理是一种相当不舒服的状态。
When we come back, what Naomi's research shows about the surprising upsides of ambivalence. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Ambivalence has many downsides. It's personally uncomfortable. It irritates our friends and colleagues. It even encourages others to take advantage of us. When we express ambivalence, people may think we are less competent or ready for leadership. But it turns out that is hardly the whole story. Naomi, you've given me a couple of examples from your life when ambivalence did not produce salutary outcomes, but I want you to tell me a story about a time when you deliberately ignored your ambivalence. Tell me about your real estate adventure in Bucks
当我们回来时，娜奥米的研究将展示矛盾心理令人惊讶的积极面。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦姆。矛盾心理有很多缺点。它在个人层面上令人不舒服。它激怒了我们的朋友和同事。它甚至鼓励其他人利用我们。当我们表达矛盾心理时，人们可能会认为我们能力较差或尚未做好领导准备。但事实证明，这远非全部。娜奥米，你举了你生活中的几个例子，当时矛盾心理并没有产生有益的结果，但我希望你讲一个你刻意忽视自己矛盾心理的故事。跟我讲讲你在宾夕法尼亚州巴克斯
County, Pennsylvania. When my husband and I got married, we had both lived in New York City for about 10 years each. And this is 10 years of living in small apartments, overpaying rent, dealing with roommates. We both really wanted to own a home. So we took trips out to the country on weekends. We kind of daydreamed about the idyllic life, living in a rural environment
郡的房地产冒险经历吧。我和丈夫结婚时，我们俩在纽约市各自生活了大约10年。这是在小公寓里生活10年，支付过高的租金，还要应付室友。我们俩都非常想拥有自己的家。所以我们在周末去乡村旅行。我们幻想着田园般的生活，生活在一个农村环境中
with these like beautiful old colonial farmhouses. And we finally found a place that we felt like was us. We fell in love with this house. It was this like remodeled farmhouse in Bucks County, just above the Delaware River. It had been remodeled by a designer from New York and it just really aesthetically appealed to both of our tastes. But at the time, I actually had these strong feelings that we might be jumping into something that we hadn't
有着这些美丽古老的殖民地农舍。我们终于找到了一个我们觉得属于我们的地方。我们爱上了这所房子。这是巴克斯郡的一座改建农舍，就在特拉华河上方。它是由一位来自纽约的设计师改建的，在审美上完全符合我们两个人的品味。但当时，我其实有强烈的预感，我们可能是在没有
fully weighed the pros and cons on, but I didn't share this with my husband. And turns out my husband was also ambivalent, but he just didn't share this with me husband. And turns out my husband was also ambivalent, but he just didn't share this with me either. And the reality was that we were not prepared for country living for a whole number of reasons. One is it took my husband over two hours one way to get to his job in New York City. Two, just like you don't get to choose your coworkers, you don't get to choose all of your neighbors. Three, it was a quite small home. Family couldn't visit very comfortably.
充分权衡利弊的情况下就仓促行事了，但我没有把这个告诉我的丈夫。结果证明我丈夫也很矛盾，但他只是没有把这告诉我也好。现实情况是，由于各种原因，我们根本没有准备好过乡村生活。第一，我丈夫单程去纽约市上班需要花两个多小时。第二，就像你无法选择同事一样，你也无法选择所有的邻居。第三，这是一个相当小的家。家人无法非常舒适地来访。
It was off the road, a road that floods. We knew nobody out there. And neither of us had actually owned a home, right? Let alone lived in the country. And nor did we know how to like take care of this beautiful and expansive garden. And we had groundhogs, we had rodents, we had deers, we had trees that fell down, we had bamboo that took over our front yard every year, we had pebbles in the driveway that would wash into the road every time it rained.
它离路很近，那是一条会淹水的路。我们在那里谁也不认识。而且我们俩实际上都没有拥有过房子，对吧？更不用说住在乡村了。我们也不知道如何照顾这个美丽而广阔的花园。我们有土拨鼠，有啮齿动物，有鹿，有倒下的树，每年都有竹子占领我们的前院，每次下雨，车道上的鹅卵石都会被冲到路上。
We had to literally rake it with our own hands. Like, every time this happened, we were just in so over our heads. We went actually over our budget to purchase it, even though we could see some of these downsides, right? We leaped because we wanted stability and we wanted closure on this long search and in our lives and we were ignoring the negative cues and in the end it was not a great choice for
我们不得不亲手用耙子去清理。就像，每次发生这种事，我们都完全力不从心。我们买房子的预算其实超支了，尽管我们可以看到其中的一些缺点，对吧？我们盲目一跃是因为我们想要稳定，想要为这漫长的寻找和我们的生活画上句号，我们忽视了消极的信号，最终这对我们来说并不是一个很好的选择。
us. We you know essentially live so far away from my spouse's work that he had to couch surf during the week in New York City at friends houses because the commute was unbearably long. I ended up, we ended up having a daughter in 2015. In 2016, I was up for tenure. I was raising her. She was a toddler and I was pregnant with our second kid and my spouse couldn't even come home during the week. So we sold the house four years after purchasing it, of course at a loss. And again, I wanted closure. I wanted my family to be together. I wanted to not be lonely that I just had to get out
你知道的，我们基本上住在离我配偶工作地点非常远的地方，以至于他不得不每周在纽约市的朋友家借宿，因为通勤时间实在太长了。我最后，我们在2015年生了一个女儿。2016年，我正在争取终身教职。我在抚养她。她是个幼儿，我又怀上了第二个孩子，而我的配偶甚至不能在工作日回家。所以我们在买下房子四年后把它卖了，当然是亏本出售。同样，我想要一个了结。我希望我的一家人能在一起。我不想感到孤独，以至于我不得不离开
The story in many ways matches what your research has found in terms of the effect that ambivalence has on the way we make judgments In one of your studies you primed participants emotional state by having them write about a time when they felt happy sad or ambivalent And then you give them an estimation task. You asked them to estimate the average daily temperature in major US cities like New York, Atlanta, and San Francisco. What did you find when you had them do this? And what do we find in general ambivalence produces in terms of the way people approach decisions? Yeah. So this was some interesting work I did with Laura Rees, Ruben Lehavy, and Jeffrey Sinches-Burks, who were all at Michigan at the time.
这个故事在许多方面与你的研究所发现的一致，即矛盾心理对我们做判断的方式产生的影响。在你的其中一项研究中，你通过让参与者写一段他们感到快乐、悲伤或矛盾的经历，来激发他们的情绪状态。然后你给他们一个估算任务。你让他们估算美国主要城市（如纽约、亚特兰大和旧金山）的平均每日气温。当你让他们做这个时，你发现了什么？总体而言，矛盾心理在人们处理决策的方式上产生了什么影响？是的。所以这是我和劳拉·里尔斯、鲁本·莱哈维以及杰弗里·辛切斯-伯克斯一起做的一些有趣的工作，他们当时都在密歇根大学。
And we primed people to feel emotional ambivalence. We had them recall a time in their life where they felt really mixed, really happy and sad at the same time, and to really write about this experience so that they could relive the experience and that somebody who was reading it would also relive that experience along with them. Right, we were really trying to put them in that state. And then we did a series of studies where we explored whether, you know, priming people to feel mixed emotions made them more open and receptive to peer advice. And then we had them do these tasks, these estimation tasks, that were unrelated to the ambivalence that they were experiencing, right?
我们激发人们产生情感上的矛盾。我们让他们回忆生活中的一个时刻，当时他们感到非常复杂，同时感到非常高兴和悲伤，并真正写下这段经历，以便他们能够重温这段经历，而阅读它的人也将能够与他们一起重温这段经历。对吧，我们真的在努力让他们进入那种状态。然后我们做了一系列研究，探讨了激发人们体验复杂情感是否会让他们对同伴的建议更加开放和接受。然后我们让他们做这些任务，这些与他们正在经历的矛盾无关的估算任务，对吧？
About the weather, you know, about college tuition rates, things that they might not have known a whole lot about. And we found that in fact, lo and behold, priming people to have mixed feelings not only made them more open and receptive to peer advice, but also more accurate in their estimates. And the way we describe this was that our emotions perhaps lead us to be biased in particular ways, but that if you have multiple emotions, the error in the bias can be canceled out. And therefore, in fact, it can make us more accurate in our predictions and in our estimates
关于天气，你知道的，关于大学学费标准，他们可能不太了解的事情。我们发现，事实的确如此，不出所料，激发人们产生复杂的情感不仅使他们更加开放和乐于接受同伴的建议，而且使他们的估计更加准确。我们对此的描述是，我们的情绪可能会导致我们以特定的方式产生偏差，但如果你有多种情绪，偏差中的误差就可以相互抵消。因此，事实上，它能使我们在对世界的预测和估计
about the world and our judgments. So much of this is premised on the idea that our emotions in some ways are providing us with signals. So when our emotions tell us something, they tell us how to respond to the world, how to behave in the world, how to walk in the world. And I think what you're showing with these studies is that ambivalence itself actually is not just a state of uncertainty. It's an approach to the study of emotions by Schwartz and Klorr who argued that affect is information, that when we have emotions that it actually provides us with information in about our environment and that emotions are actually here for a reason.
以及我们的判断中更加准确。这很大程度上基于这样一个观点，即我们的情绪在某种程度上为我们提供了信号。因此，当我们的情绪告诉我们某些事情时，它们是在告诉我们如何对世界做出反应，如何在世界中行事，如何在世界中漫步。我认为你在这些研究中展示的是，矛盾心理本身实际上不仅仅是一种不确定性状态。这是施瓦茨和克洛尔对情绪研究的一种方法，他们认为情感就是信息，当我们有情绪时，它实际上为我们提供了关于环境的信息，情绪的存在实际上是有原因的。
And if you pay attention to your emotional cues, it can signal perhaps an appropriate response to the challenges that you might be facing. And so we know that from a whole large, beautiful body of work by Jeff Larson, that mixed emotions, emotional ambivalence, tend to be triggered by pretty emotionally complex situations like college graduation day,
如果你关注你的情绪线索，它可能会提示你对可能面临的挑战做出适当的反应。因此，我们从杰夫·拉森的大量精美研究中了解到，复杂的情感、情感矛盾，往往是由相当情感复杂的环境触发的，比如大学毕业日、
dormitory move out day, watching the movie Life is Beautiful, and that these are pretty contradictory, complex situations. And so one thought that Shimon Malani and I have written about is, you know, maybe emotional ambivalence exists in part to help us solve contradictory and complex problems. So another way to put this, perhaps, might be is that one of the functions of an emotion-like ambivalence is to protect us against impulsive decisions. I think that's absolutely right. In fact, I'm conducting right now a meta-analysis with some scholars at UT Austin,
宿舍搬迁日，观看电影《美丽人生》，这些是相当矛盾和复杂的环境。因此，我和希蒙·马拉尼写过的一个想法是，你知道的，也许情感矛盾的存在部分是为了帮助我们解决矛盾和复杂的问题。换一种说法，也许，情感矛盾这样的功能之一就是保护我们免受冲动的决定。我认为这绝对是对的。事实上，我现在正和德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校的一些学者合作进行一项元分析，
where we're really trying to unpack the conditions under which ambivalence yields greater learning and exploration, versus the conditions under which it leads to less exploration and learning. And one of the things that we have identified is that in this closure imperative, this desire to have an answer, get closure on a decision,
我们真正试图剖析的是矛盾心理产生更多学习和探索的条件，与导致更少探索和学习的条件之间的差异。我们确定的其中一件事是，在这种对结论的迫切需求中，即渴望得到一个答案、对一个决定做出了解、
move forward in our lives, we really may do less exploration of the information that exists in our world. But guess what? Under low closure imperative, you do more exploration and learning. So being in an ambivalent state of mind changes the way we think in a range of different ways. I want to play you a clip from the movie Father of the Bride.
在生活中继续前进，我们可能真的会减少对存在于我们世界中的信息的探索。但你猜怎么着？在低结论需求的驱动下，你会进行更多的探索和学习。因此，处于矛盾的心态会以各种不同的方式改变我们的思维方式。我想放一段电影《新岳父大人》的片段。
In this scene, the actor Steve Martin is playing a dad whose daughter is about to get married. I realized at that moment that I was never going to come home again and see Annie at the top of the stairs, never going to see her again at our breakfast table in her nightgown and socks. I suddenly realized what was happening. Annie was all grown up and leaving us. And something inside began to hurt. So Naomi, researchers have used this movie clip to give people a sense of what it's like to feel ambivalence. Can you tell me about the research experiments they've conducted and what they found? Yeah, so this is the kind of foundational research
在这个场景中，演员史蒂夫·马丁扮演一位女儿即将结婚的父亲。我那一刻意识到，我再也不会回家看到安妮站在楼梯顶上了，再也看不到她穿着睡衣和袜子坐在我们的早餐桌旁了。我突然意识到发生了什么。安妮长大了，要离开我们了。内心某处开始作痛。所以，娜奥米，研究人员利用这个电影片段来让人们感受矛盾心理是什么样的。你能跟我讲讲他们进行的科学实验以及他们的发现吗？是的，这就是关于
on emotional ambivalence that Christina Fong conducted. What she was able to do was prime people to feel emotional ambivalence through clips like this, and then had them engage in creativity tasks. And this is the work that has very much inspired a lot of the scholarship on the benefits of emotional ambivalence, particularly for cognitive flexibility and other outcomes like that. What she was able to show was that priming people to feel mixed emotions tells people that they may be in an unusual environment and that it cues to them unusual associations in the subsequent tasks that
克莉丝蒂娜·方进行的情感矛盾的基础研究。她能够通过这样的片段激发人们体验情感矛盾，然后让他们参与创造力任务。这项工作在很大程度上启发了关于情感矛盾的好处的大量学术研究，特别是对于认知灵活性和其他类似结果的好处。她能够证明的是，激发人们体验复杂的情感告诉人们他们可能处于一个不寻常的环境中，并在他们随后参与的
they engage in. And we've done some research recently where we've shown that feeling emotional ambivalence makes you more cognitively flexible. And what I mean by that is that you not only think about concepts in a more broad and inclusive way, if you're feeling ambivalent, you'll actually process information in a more cognitively flexible manner.
任务中向他们提示不寻常的联想。我们最近做了一些研究，表明体验情感矛盾能让你在认知上更加灵活。我的意思是，如果你感到矛盾，你不仅会以更广泛和包容的方式思考概念，你实际上会以更具认知灵活性的方式处理信息。
In other words, when we feel ambivalence, our minds are processing a situation that feels complicated. When we shut down ambivalence, we can shut down thinking in complex ways about an issue. We start to prioritize decisiveness over accuracy. There's another important insight here. When we permit ambivalence, we can also change how the people around us are thinking. Naomi has found that people who express ambivalence can help to move negotiation partners toward a result that works well for everyone.
换句话说，当我们感到矛盾时，我们的思维正在处理一个感觉复杂的局势。当我们关闭矛盾心理时，我们就会关闭对一个问题进行复杂思考的方式。我们开始优先考虑果断性而不是准确性。这里还有另一个重要的见解。当我们允许矛盾心理存在时，我们也可以改变身边人的思考方式。娜奥米发现，表达矛盾心理的人可以帮助推动谈判伙伴走向一个对所有人都有利的结局。
Yes. So the research I conducted initially that people react kind of dominantly towards their ambivalent partner, particularly when they're in these competitive negotiations, right? Where my win is your loss, your loss is my win. But I wasn't satisfied completely with that answer. And so I set out to examine with Greg Northcraft, what happens when you change the social norms? What happens when you actually encourage people to cooperate with their ambivalent counterpart?
是的。因此我最初进行的研究表明，人们对他们的矛盾伙伴反应往往是占主导地位的，特别是当他们处于这些竞争性的谈判中时，对吧？也就是我的赢就是你的输，你的输就是我的赢。但我对这个答案并不完全满意。所以我着手与格雷格·诺斯克拉夫特一起检查，当你改变社会规范时会发生什么？当你真正鼓励人们与他们矛盾的对应方合作时会发生什么？
Does ambivalence have a different effect in that more cooperative setting? And I trained an actor from the Tisch School of Arts to express ambivalence. She was torn and conflicted in her nonverbal behavior. And I had negotiators watch a video of this partner before they engaged in negotiation with her and report their perceptions of her. She was perceived just as in my prior studies as less dominant.
矛盾心理在那个更具合作性的环境中会有不同的影响吗？我训练了蒂施艺术学院的一名演员来表达矛盾心理。她在非言语行为中表现得纠结和冲突。我让谈判人员在与她进行谈判之前观看这个伙伴的视频，并报告对她的看法。她被认为和我的先前的研究一样，支配性较弱。
But in the negotiations with cooperative goals, where I wanna win, but not at your expense, that ambivalence in that context, in fact, inspired better outcomes. But it seems like it has to do with setting a cooperative context to create social norms where we're sitting actually on the same side of the table, that we realize that this is a complex problem, we're working interdependently, and that that's precisely the situation where your ambivalence makes me work a little harder,
但在具有合作目标的谈判中，即我想赢，但不以牺牲你为代价，在这种背景下的矛盾，实际上激发了更好的结果。但这似乎与建立合作背景有关，以创造社会规范，让我们实际上坐在桌子的同一侧，我们意识到这是一个复杂的问题，我们正在相互依存地工作，而这正是你的矛盾心理让我更努力一点、
makes me problem solve a little bit better. We talked earlier about how we have stereotypes of leaders and leadership, whereby we see decisive leaders as being competent leaders, effective leaders, and people who come across as ambivalent as indecisive or incompetent. But there's also been work looking at how leaders who are ambivalent are able to take in more information about complex situations. Can you talk about this work? I mean, what is the upside of ambivalence when it comes to leadership?
让我更好地解决问题的局面。我们之前讨论过我们对领导者和领导力的刻板印象，即我们将果断的领导者视为称职的领导者、有效的领导者，而将那些表现得矛盾的人视为优柔寡断或不称职。但也有研究探讨了矛盾的领导者如何能够吸收更多关于复杂局势的信息。你能谈谈这项工作吗？我的意思是，说到领导力，矛盾心理的好处是什么？
Yeah, so I just really love this research where we have been exploring both in experimental laboratory contexts as well as in the real world with consultants, you know, what is the effect of having a leader who's torn and conflicted, who's ambivalent about a project. And what we have found across these three separate studies
是的，我非常喜欢这项研究，我们在实验实验室环境以及现实世界中与顾问一起探索，你知道，有一个纠结和冲突、对项目感到矛盾的领导者会产生什么影响。我们在所有这三项独立研究中发现的是
is that leaders who are ambivalent, in fact, seek more information from their team members. And that has this benefit of then modeling a style of leadership that's perhaps more democratic, and the team members start seeking more information from each other, and the team performs better compared to when leaders experience less ambivalence. But there's a paradox here. So ambivalence is, we punish ambivalence when leaders express them, but it turns out ambivalence helps make people better leaders. How do you solve this paradox? I have started to answer this question in some of my work. I think this is where the science currently stands, is wanting to understand when is it going to be
感到矛盾的领导者实际上会从他们的团队成员那里寻求更多的信息。这具有一种好处，即塑造了一种可能更加民主的领导风格，团队成员开始互相寻求更多信息，与领导者体验较少矛盾的情况相比，团队表现更好。但这里有一个悖论。因此，矛盾心理是，当领导者表达矛盾时，我们会惩罚矛盾，但事实证明矛盾有助于使人成为更好的领导者。你如何解决这个悖论？我已经在自己的一些工作中开始回答这个问题。我认为这正是科学目前所处的位置，想要了解什么时候会有
fruitful and when is it not. When you have ambivalence and you share it in a highly individualistic, competitive situation, it's not going to serve you. But if you can first create cooperative norms where we're on the same side, that that's the first step for then harnessing the benefits of sharing our ambivalence with others. I'm thinking though in the political sphere, when you're running for office, I mean that's in some ways the definition of a zero-sum game. You know, if you win, I lose. If I win, you lose. Only one person can win an election. Is it possible that expressing ambivalence in the course of a campaign is in fact dangerous and counterproductive to actually getting elected. But once you are elected, expressing ambivalence,
富有成效，什么时候不会。当你感到矛盾并在高度个人主义、竞争激烈的环境中分享它时，它对你没有帮助。但如果你能首先建立合作规范，让我们站在同一边，那是利用与他人分享矛盾心理的好处的首要步骤。不过我想在政治领域，当你竞选公职时，在某种程度上这就是零和博弈的定义。你知道，如果你赢了，我输了。如果我赢了，你输了。只有一个人能赢得选举。在竞选过程中表达矛盾心理是否实际上是危险的，并且对真正当选适得其反？但一旦你当选，表达矛盾心理，
especially within, you know, closed door settings where you're surrounded by other people who are trying to come to the right decision on a matter of policy might actually be effective. So in other words, is it possible that we need to be strategic not just about when we experience ambivalence, but when we express it? Oh, yeah, I love that.
尤其是在闭门会议中，当你周围都是试图对政策问题做出正确决定的其他人时，实际上可能会很有效。换句话说，我们是否不仅需要对我们何时体验矛盾心理具有战略性，还需要对我们何时表达它具有战略性？哦，是的，我喜欢这个。
And so we have shown in some research recently that, yeah, you're not gonna promote the ambivalent leader, but you know what? They actually are also perceived as more ethical. They actually also are more likely to take the perspective of their employees, right? And in fact, be more effective once they get there.
所以我们在最近的一些研究中表明，是的，你不会提拔那个矛盾的领导者，但你知道吗？他们实际上也被认为更具道德感。他们实际上也更有可能站在员工的角度考虑问题，对吧？事实上，一旦他们到达那里，就会更有效率。
There's also been some really fascinating work here, Naomi, looking at how ambivalence might change how we orient ourselves towards the meaning of life, how much meaning we derive from life. Can you talk about this work? What's the relationship between experiencing ambivalence and being able to derive greater meaning from our existence? Yeah, so there's this really fascinating research by Raoul Berrios and colleagues that is kind of inspired by some writing
娜奥米，这里还有一些非常迷人的研究，着眼于矛盾心理如何改变我们对生命意义的定位，我们从生活中获得多少意义。你能谈谈这项工作吗？体验矛盾心理与能够从我们的存在中获得更多意义之间有什么关系？是的，劳尔·贝里奥斯和同事们有一项非常迷人的研究，它受到杰夫·拉森几年前的一些著作的启发，
that Jeff Larson did several years ago, who argued that when you have mixed emotions, it allows you to kind of take both the good with the bad. And in the research by Raoul, found that, in fact, when you have mixed emotions, perhaps in the face of contradictory goals, that you also are more likely to experience eudaemonic well-being, which is a form of well-being that is rooted in meaning making.
他认为，当你拥有复杂的情感时，它能让你兼顾好与坏。劳尔的研究发现，事实上，当你拥有复杂的情感时，也许在面对相互矛盾的目标时，你也更有可能体验到尤代蒙福祉（eudaimonic well-being），这是一种植根于意义构建的福祉形式。
So essentially, it finds that there's this importance of having mixed emotions in the search for meaning in life and for resolving our conflicted goals. So in some ways, being able to see that we are pulled in different ways allows us in some ways to see the complexity of the shades of life, if you will, and perhaps see how rich that tapestry can be. I think that's exactly right.
所以本质上，它发现拥有复杂的情感在寻找生命意义和解决我们冲突的目标中具有这种重要性。所以在某种程度上，能够看到我们被不同的方向拉扯，在某种程度上使我们能够看到生命阴影的复杂性，如果你愿意的话，也许能看到这幅挂毯可以多么丰富。我认为这完全正确。
When we come back, how to put ambivalence to work in your own life. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Is Ambivalence a Good Thing or a Bad Thing? Is Ambivalence a Good Thing or a Bad Thing? Turns out, my answer to that question is ambivalent. Ambivalence can help us see the world more clearly and act more creatively, but it can also make us feel uncomfortable and seem weak. Naomi, you grew up with a model of someone who productively used ambivalence in his daily
当我们回来时，如何在自己的生活中运用矛盾心理。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦姆。矛盾心理是件好事还是坏事？矛盾心理是件好事还是坏事？事实证明，我对这个问题的回答是矛盾的。矛盾心理可以帮助我们更清晰地看世界，行动更有创造力，但它也会让我们感到不舒服并显得软弱。娜奥米，你在成长过程中有一个人的榜样，他在日常生活中富有成效地运用了矛盾心理
life. Who was this person and where did his love of ambivalence come from? Yes. So I've been thinking long and hard about how my father influenced me with respect to my own research. And so, yeah, my dad was this guy from New York. He spent several years in the late 60s and 70s
生活。这个人是谁？他对矛盾心理的喜爱又是从何而来的呢？是的。所以我一直在深思我的父亲是如何在我的研究方面对我产生影响的。所以，是的，我爸爸是个来自纽约的人。在60年代末和70年代的几年里，
working towards a PhD in Renaissance Literature at UC Berkeley, where he met my mother. And he actually never finished his dissertation because he was drawn away by a larger purpose to teach writing at UC Santa Cruz. And he saw this as a way to give people voice and thereby kind of support their participation in democracy. And he was just beloved.
他在加州大学伯克利分校攻读文艺复兴文学的博士学位，并正是在那里遇到了我母亲。事实上，他从未完成博士论文，因为他被一个更伟大的目标吸引走了——去加州大学圣克鲁斯分校教授写作。他认为这是一种赋予人们话语权的方式，从而在某种程度上支持他们参与民主。而且他深受欢迎。
He was beloved by his students. He was beloved by his colleagues, his bosses. Hundreds of people came to his memorial service, and they wanted to speak about kind of the impact, his impact on their lives and how he changed their lives. And in a few cases, people even told me that he saved their lives. So you can imagine he's taught me many things, but two pivotal lessons were about ambivalence. The first was to identify ambivalence in the world.
他的学生都爱戴他。他的同事和老板也都爱戴他。数百人参加了他的追悼会，他们都想谈谈他对他们生活的某种影响、他对他们生活的改变，以及他是如何改变他们的人生。在少数情况下，人们甚至告诉我他救了他们的命。所以你可以想象，他教给我很多东西，但其中两个至关重要的教导都关于矛盾心理。第一是要学会在世界上识别矛盾心理。
And the second is the value of ambivalence as a leadership strength. So my dad taught me to identify ambivalence through Shakespeare plays. During my childhood, we went to like every single Shakespeare play performed by Shakespeare Santa Cruz. And I'll never forget this other thing that my dad used to do all the time.
第二则是将矛盾心理视为一种领导力优势的价值。所以，我爸爸是通过莎士比亚的戏剧教导我识别矛盾心理的。在我的童年时期，我们几乎看遍了圣克鲁斯莎士比亚剧团上演的每一场莎士比亚戏剧。而且我永远不会忘记我爸爸过去常常做的另一件事。
I went to college at UC Davis and when he would drive me to campus, there's an exit near Fairfield, California called Cordelia. And so without fail, every time we drove past this exit, my dad would always retell the story of Cordelia in King Lear. And it's the story of a complex relationship between a father and a daughter.
我在加州大学戴维斯分校上大学，当他开车送我去校园时，在加州费尔菲尔德附近有一个叫科迪莉亚的出口。因此，毫无例外地，每次我们开车经过这个出口时，我爸爸总是会重述《李尔王》中科迪莉亚的故事。这是一个关于父亲和女儿之间复杂关系的故事。
Lear asks for professions of love from his three daughters to determine basically how to divide the land of his kingdom between them. And Cordelia's sisters, Gonoril and Regan, give deceitfully lavish speeches that basically profess their love, flatter his vanity, right? And Cordelia basically sees right through her sister's feigned professions of love and kind of refuses to do the same. And Lear deems her answer as too simple. And he asks her, what can you say to draw a third more opulent than your sisters speak?
李尔要求他的三个女儿表达爱意，以此来决定基本上如何把他的王国土地在她们之间瓜分。科迪莉亚的姐姐们高纳里尔和里根发表了虚伪而华丽的演讲，基本上表达了她们的爱意，奉承了他的虚荣心，对吧？而科迪莉亚基本上看穿了她姐姐们假装的爱意表白，并且在某种程度上拒绝这样做。李尔认为她的回答太简单了。他问她：“你还能说什么，好让我分给你的土地比你姐姐们更丰厚呢？”
And Cordelia replies, nothing, my Lord. Unhappy that I am, I cannot heave my heart into my mouth. I love your majesty according to my bond. No more, no less. And Lear then exiles her as a response to her honesty. And so, clearly there's just a lot to unpack here, but especially as the daughter of somebody who totally was beloved by so many people, right?
科迪莉亚回答说：“没有，我的大人。不幸如我，我无法将我的心托在嘴边。我按照我的本分爱您的陛下。不多不少。”作为对她诚实的回应，李尔随后流放了她。所以，很显然这里有很多值得剖析的地方，尤其是作为一个被这么多人完全喜爱的人的女儿，对吧？
But one of the things that I learned from these conversations was to notice ambivalence, to notice it in relationships, in emotions, in the world, and that ambivalence, contradiction, complexity are just a core part of our lived experience, and it deserves to be noticed. He also taught me the value of ambivalence, and particularly for leaders, and he did this through his interpersonal style.
但我从这些对话中学到的事情之一，就是去注意到矛盾心理，在人际关系、情感和世界中注意到它，而且矛盾心理、矛盾和复杂性正是我们生活体验的核心部分，它值得被注意到。他还教导我矛盾心理的价值，特别是对领导者而言，他是通过自己的人际交往风格来做到这一点的。
So you might wonder what in the world does this even look like? Well, my dad often sounded like he was quite torn and conflicted. He would rarely just agree or disagree. My mom has said that this could be rather frustrating, but he was resistant to taking sides. He was uncomfortable with premature certainty. And in fact, on his tombstone, we have a quote from Shakespeare's play,
所以你可能会好奇，这究竟是什么样子的？嗯，我爸爸经常听起来像是陷入了纠结和冲突之中。他很少会直接表示同意或不同意。我妈妈曾说过，这可能会相当令人沮丧，但他很不愿选边站队。他对过早的确定性感到不自在。事实上，在他的墓碑上，我们刻了莎士比亚戏剧中的一句名言：
"'As You Like It,' which is, much virtue in if. And the full quote is, "'Your if is the only peacemaker.' Much virtue in if." And so this really epitomizes him as an educator, as an administrator, as a father. You know, he was really just at his best in conversation with other people. He was so curious. He was so ambivalent. He was so open-ended. He loved to ask hard questions. He would often start his sentences with things like, well, what if? Or perhaps, or I wonder. And there was just so much virtue in it,
“《皆大欢喜》里的一句话是：‘“如果”一词大有学问。’而完整的一句是：‘你的“如果”是唯一的调停者。大有学问在“如果”中。’”所以这真正完美地刻画了他作为一名教育家、管理者和父亲的形象。你知道，他在与他人的交谈中确实表现得最好。他是如此充满好奇心。他是如此具有矛盾心理。他是如此思维开放。他喜欢问难题。他经常用这样的话来开始他的句子：嗯，如果会怎样？或者也许，或者我在想。而其中蕴含着如此之多的学问，
right? He actually helped people work through difficult problems. And so, you know, it's totally undeniable that his interpersonal style inspired my research on the benefits of sharing your emotional ambivalence. So researchers have found that people who like your father embrace So researchers have found that people who like your father embrace What's sometimes called a paradox mindset are able to use ambivalence? Effectively what what exactly is a paradox mindset Naomi? This is this fascinating research Conducted by scholars including Ella Mir and specter Amy Ingram Josh Keller Wendy Smith Marian Lewis who suggested that if you develop a paradox mindset where you consider the world with a both and approach instead of an either or
对吧？他实际上帮助人们解决难题。所以，你知道，毫无疑问，他的人际交往风格启发了我对分享情感矛盾心理之益处的研究。因此研究人员发现，像你父亲那样的人拥抱——因此研究人员发现，像你父亲那样的人拥抱——有时被称为悖论思维的东西，能够运用矛盾心理吗？实际上，这究竟是什么——什么是悖论思维，娜奥米？这是由包括埃拉·米尔、斯佩克特、艾米·英格拉姆、乔什·凯勒、温迪··史密斯、玛丽安·刘易斯在内的学者所进行的迷人研究，他们指出，如果你培养出一种悖论思维，以“两全其美”的方法而不是非此即彼的方法来看待世界，
approach, it can be really helpful for dealing with competing demands. And so one assumption is that competing demands, like the ones that people have really experienced through the pandemic, are very uncomfortable. And what these authors found was that although tensions tend to arise when you have these competing demands, the tensions themselves are not the problem. It's actually people's mindsets. And if people believe that addressing one demand means neglecting another, that they're going to struggle. But with a paradox mindset, people accept and they learn to live
这对于处理相互冲突的需求会非常有用。因此，其中一个假设是，相互冲突的需求（就像人们在疫情期间真正经历过的那样）是非常令人不舒服的。这些作者发现的是，尽管当面临这些相互冲突的需求时往往会产生紧张感，但紧张感本身并不是问题所在。实际上是人们的心态。如果人们认为满足一个需求就意味着忽视另一个需求，他们就会苦苦挣扎。但有了悖论思维，人们就能接受并学会与
with the tensions that are associated with their competing demands and they realize that one demand can actually enable another and that they might need both of them to thrive. In many ways, I think the paradox mindset might be the solution to a problem that we discussed earlier, which is that ambivalence is a naturally uncomfortable state. Many of us try and simplify the problems we're seeing to come down on one side or the other. But of course, we've also seen that ambivalence
与他们相互冲突的需求相关的紧张感共存，他们会意识到一个需求实际上可以促成另一个需求，而且他们可能需要这两者才能蓬勃发展。在许多方面，我认为悖论思维可能是我们之前讨论过的一个问题的解决方案，即矛盾心理是一种自然不舒服的状态。我们许多人试图简化我们看到的问题，从而倾向于倒向某一边。但当然，我们也看到过矛盾心理
allows us to see the world in all kinds of complex, interesting and creative ways. So the paradox mindset says, if you can increase people's capacity to tolerate the discomfort of ambivalence, you can derive the benefits of ambivalence without being overwhelmed by the discomfort of it. Is that summarizing the idea? I think that is summarizing the idea beautifully, and I think it's actually still a hypothesis. I think we're still wanting to unpack exactly the role that paradox mindset
能让我们以各种复杂、有趣和有创意的方式看待世界。所以悖论思维说，如果你能提高人们忍受矛盾心理带来的不适感的能力，你就能从中获得矛盾心理的好处，而不会被它的不适感所压垮。这就是对这个概念的总结吗？我认为这把这个概念总结得非常美妙，而且我认为这其实仍然是一个假设。我认为我们仍然想要剖析悖论思维究竟起到了什么作用
might have in helping people harness the benefits of ambivalence and deal with the discomfort. There are some situations where deliberately cultivating ambivalence can be a way of managing or limiting disappointment. Can you talk about that, sort of using ambivalence almost strategically to head off disappointment or to head off feelings of failure or setback? Yeah, so this is this really interesting research where people, in fact, are found to cultivate ambivalence when they face uncertainty about what will happen. So perhaps they feel uncertain that they can obtain a coveted job. And in order to protect their feelings in the event that they fail to get
可能有助于人们利用矛盾心理的好处并应对不适感。在某些情况下，刻意培养矛盾心理可以成为一种管理或限制失望情绪的方法。你能谈谈这个吗，也就是几乎出于战略性地使用矛盾心理来预防失望，或者预防挫折感或挫败感？是的，所以这是一项非常有趣的研究，事实上，人们在面对未来会发生什么感到不确定时，会被发现会培养矛盾心理。也许他们对能否得到梦寐以求的工作感到不确定。为了在未能得到想要的东西时保护自己的感受，
what they want, they create mixed emotions or mixed attitudes as a self-protective strategy to buffer their feelings from failure. I have had experiences in my own life where I have done this as well. Can you talk about them, Naomi? Absolutely. So it's kind of a funny story, I mean now in retrospect, right? Which is that when dating my spouse, I really wanted it to work out with him. But I was of course uncertain if it would because you just never know. And I remember going on vacation with my brother's family and while I was away for that week,
他们创造了混合的情绪或混合的态度，作为一种自我保护的策略，来缓冲失败给他们带来的情感冲击。我在自己的生活中也有过这样的经历，我也曾这样做过。你能谈谈这些经历吗，娜奥米？当然可以。所以这是一个挺有趣的故事，我是指现在回想起来，对吧？也就是当我在和我的配偶谈恋爱时，我非常希望这段感情能修成正果。但我当然不确定是否能成，因为你永远不知道。我记得和哥哥的家人一起去度假，在那周我不在的期间，
I built up these very mixed feelings about my spouse. And it's obvious now to see that it was definitely a self-protective strategy in the face of possible rejection. I was preemptively protecting myself by cultivating ambivalence. And I actually think that it made both my spouse and myself think more deeply about the other person, to really see each other, to see both the positives and the negatives, and whether we were a match.
我对我的配偶产生了这种非常复杂的感情。现在看来，显而易见，在可能遭到拒绝的面前，这绝对是一种自我保护的策略。我通过培养矛盾心理来先发制人地保护自己。而且我真的认为，这使得我和我的配偶都对对方有了更深入的思考，去真正地看清彼此，看到积极面和消极面，以及我们是否真正般配。
And I actually would say I was accurate. He's my favorite person. And perhaps my ability to predict our match was cultivated by my emotional ambivalence. In some ways you did with him what you didn't do with the house in Bucks County. You know, by allowing yourself to engage in ambivalence, you were able to see things perhaps more clearly, and in the long run that might have actually been an asset. I think you're so right. You know, I'm struck by the fact, Naomi, that your research in some ways has been inspired by events in your own life, but also you have taken the strands of your research and tried to apply it to your own life, to experiences you've gone through yourself.
而且我其实想说我很准确。他是我最喜欢的人。或许我预测我们是否般配的能力是由我的情感矛盾心理培养出来的。在某些方面，你对他的做法就像你对巴克斯县那所房子的做法一样。你知道，通过让自己沉浸于矛盾心理中，你或许能够更清晰地看清事物，从长远来看，这实际上可能是一种资产。我觉得你说得太对了。娜奥米，我深有感触的是，一方面你的研究在某种程度上受到了你个人生活中事件的启发，但另一方面你也吸收了你研究的脉络，并试图将其应用到你自己的生活中，应用到你自己经历过的事情上。
I'm wondering if you can tell me about the time when your mom was really sick and how you applied the insights from your own research to what your mom was going through. Certainly. So, a year and a half into the COVID pandemic, my mother noticed that she had some shortness of breath and months later they diagnosed her with early stage lung cancer. And she was not somebody who had been a smoker, but her parents had also had lung cancer. And she was going to have surgery. I flew out to support her through the surgery and we were sitting in the hospital room waiting
我想知道你能否告诉我，你妈妈病得很重的那段时期，你是如何将自己研究中的深刻见解应用到你妈妈所经历的事情上的。当然可以。新冠疫情爆发一年半后，我母亲发现自己有些气短，几个月后他们诊断她患上了早期肺癌。她并不是一个吸烟者，但她的父母也曾患过肺癌。她将要接受手术。我飞过去支持她度过手术期，我们坐在病房里等待
five hours for the surgeon to be ready. And I remember feeling these waves of anxiety. You know, I kind of noticed that I kept having the urge to amplify my positive emotions and to suppress my worry and my anxiety. And when I was younger, I would often amplify my positive emotions, and I was younger, I would often amplify my positive emotions and I would suppress my negative one.
外科医生准备就绪，足足等了五个小时。我记得当时感到了阵阵焦虑。你知道，我注意到自己不断有一种冲动，想要放大积极情绪，压抑我的担忧和焦虑。当我更年轻的时候，我经常会放大我的积极情绪，而我更年轻的时候，我经常会放大我的积极情绪，
I used to have these mantras that I kind of wrote on little soccer balls and gave to my friends, which was like, it's what you make of it, or make the best of it, or mind over matter, right? And I think that that was a more kind of or less mature way of kind of dealing with my emotions, but not an uncommon one.
我会压抑我的消极情绪。我过去常有一些座右铭，我把它们写在小足球上送给我的朋友，比如，事情由你如何看待它而定，或者尽力而为，或者意志力战胜物质，对吧？我认为那是一种比较或多或少不太成熟的处理情绪的方式，但并非不常见。
And so what I had found was that these mantras didn't really help. And in this moment in the hospital room, I kind of caught myself trying to do this cheerleading along the lines of, lines of, you're doing great. Good job, mom. These like kind of throw away positive affirmations that we kind of so frequently use to kind of manage the moods in the group or in the room. And what I have learned to do
所以我发现的是，这些座右铭并没有真正起到作用。在医院病房的这一刻，我发现自己试图沿着这样的路线进行加油打气：你做得真棒。干得好，妈妈。这些有点像那种我们经常用来管理群体或房间里情绪的随意的积极肯定。而我学会做的是
is to actually process my negative emotions instead of suppress them. It's something that I practice. It's something I'm pretty intentional about, noticing my feelings, identifying them, and being curious about them. And so what I found myself doing in my mom's hospital room was to just stop and to notice that I was having
其实是去处理我的消极情绪，而不是压抑它们。这是我一直在练习的事情。这是我相当刻意去做的事情，去注意到我的感受，识别它们，并对它们保持好奇。所以我在我妈妈的病房里发现自己在做的事情，就是停下来，注意到我当时有
this inclination to kind of amplify the positive and suppress the negative. And I don't want to judge people for doing that. But I think for my mother and myself, it's just not true to us. And so I wanted to honor the truth, I think, of the emotional situation, the situation we found ourselves in in the hospital room.
这种倾向，想要放大积极面而压抑消极面。我并不想评判那些这样做了的人。但我认为对于我母亲和我自己来说，这并不是真实的自我。所以我想尊重情感状况的真相，也就是我们在病房里发现自己所处的那种状况的真相。
And perhaps, like Cordelia, I didn't want to lie. And what did you say to her? What did you say to your mom? How did you express the negatives? I said, Mom, you know, I'm noticing that I'm having this inclination to one cheerleader you and to boost us up. And it's because I'm noticing that I'm having this inclination to want to cheerlead you and to boost us up. And it's because I'm anxious. You know, I'm feeling worried and I want to do my best
也许，就像科迪莉亚一样，我不想说谎。你对她说了什么？你对你妈妈说了什么？你是如何表达消极情绪的？我说，妈妈，你知道，我注意到我有这种倾向，想为你加油打气，让我们振作起来。这是因为我注意到我有这种倾向，想要为你加油打气，并让我们振作起来。这是因为我很焦虑。你知道，我感到担忧，我想尽最大努力
not to just suppress that. And what was the effect of doing this on your mom, do you think, that you were expressing not just, you know, your cheerleading and optimism, but also putting in place the context of your anxiety and worry? You know, if my own experience tells me anything, it's that when people acknowledge their mixed feelings
不只是把这种情绪压抑下去。你认为这样做对你妈妈有什么影响，你不仅表达了你的加油和乐观，还将你的焦虑和担忧的背景融入其中？你知道，如果我自己的经验能说明什么的话，那就是当人们以诚实、真实、地道的方式承认他们的复杂感受时，
in an honest and real, authentic way, that it's comforting to others, particularly to those who are also feeling emotional ambivalence or mixed feelings, that it's completely normal and natural. Do you feel like your mom felt that way? I mean, did you say anything either before or since that acknowledged to you that in fact she did find it helpful to hear you express both the positive and the negative? Yeah, so my mother in the moment doesn't often share her feelings, but she does this beautiful
这对他人来说是一种安慰，尤其是对那些也感到情感矛盾或复杂感受的人来说，这完全是正常和自然的。你觉得你妈妈也是这种感觉吗？我是说，你之前或之后说过任何话，向你表明她确实觉得听到你同时表达积极和消极情绪很有帮助吗？是的，所以我母亲当时并不经常分享她的感受，但她做了一件很美妙的事情，
thing where she sends me letters and notes. I asked Naomi to read me the letter her mother sent her after the surgery. She writes, Dear Naomi, In the conversation we had, I felt so totally seen and understood. I felt as though you know me deeply better than anyone in my life now. Thank you for being the intelligent, probing, compassionate person you are. I feel so blessed and proud to be your mother. I feel as though you found your way to carry on dad's work in the important contribution you have to make about the difficulty and the importance
她给我写信和便条。我请娜奥米读一读她母亲在手术后写给她的信。她写道：“亲爱的娜奥米，在我们刚才的谈话中，我感到自己被完全看到和理解了。我感觉你比我生命中现在的任何人都要深刻地了解我。谢谢你成为这样一个聪明、刨根问底、富有同情心的你。作为你的母亲，我感到如此幸运和骄傲。我觉得你已经找到了传承父亲工作的方式，并在关于拥抱矛盾心理和搁置过早的确定性这一困难与重要性方面做出了重要的贡献。爱你的妈妈。”娜奥米·罗斯曼是里海大学的心理学家。娜奥米，我可以毫无矛盾地说，非常感谢你今天来到我们的节目《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-帕尔、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。
of embracing ambivalence and holding off premature certainty. Love, mom. Naomi Rothman is a psychologist at Lehigh University. Naomi, I can say this without ambivalence. Thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury.
塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行主编。今天我们将以来自我们姐妹节目《我无名的英雄》的一个故事结束。本期《我无名的英雄》由 T-Mobile for Business 赞助播出。我们的故事来自安迪·戴维斯。几年前，安迪和他的妻子决定骑自行车横跨全国。他们为这次冒险进行了数月的训练。但在2020年的一天，就在他们计划出发前几个月，
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. We end today with a story from our sister show, My Unsung Hero. This My Unsung Hero segment is brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. Our story comes from Andy Davis. A few years ago, Andy and his wife decided to ride their bikes across the country. They spent months training for their adventure. But one day in 2020, just a few months before they planned to leave,
安迪感到胸口一阵剧痛。我被直升机两次送往不同的医院。我的病情得到了控制，并在之后陷入了心力衰竭。这太不可思议了，因为我身体状况一直很好。仅仅几个月后，我在自己家里几乎都只能步履蹒跚地挪动了。到了11月，我被列入了心脏移植等待名单。如果你被列入了心脏移植名单，你根本不知道自己能不能得到一颗心脏。如果你被列入了名单，你根本不知道自己能不能得到一颗心脏，
Andy felt an intense pain across his chest. I was sent by helicopter twice to different hospitals. I was stabilized and I emerged from that in heart failure. And it was incredible because I was so fit. And just a couple months later, I could barely shuffle around my own home. By November, I was placed on the heart transplant list. And you don't know if you're gonna get a heart if you're placed on the heart transplant list. And you don't know if you're gonna get a heart
你只能抱有希望。我的病情恶化得非常快。因此，我的主动脉里放置了一个球囊，我以前从未做过这种治疗，但那维持了11天。到了第12天，也就是12月12日，我得知我的新心脏正在运送途中，我怀着希望进入手术室，希望能看到人们和我的家人在手术的另一端等我。
if you're placed on the list, you just hope. And my condition deteriorated really quickly. And so a balloon was placed in my aorta, which I'd never had that done before, but that lasted for 11 days. And on the 12th day, December 12th, I learned that my new heart was on its way and went into surgery hoping that I would see people and my family on the other side.
我永远没能见到我的无名英雄。她的名字叫莎拉·艾维。通过与她丈夫的交谈，我知道她是一位母亲和妻子，而此时此刻她现在字面意义上成为了我的一部分。我已经带着我的新心脏生活了一年多。信不信由你，我和妻子现在正梦想着再次进行那次跨国自行车旅行。我感到震惊，并为自己仍然活着、还能和家人在一起这个事实感到惊叹。我想到了莎拉和她的家人，他们在那些难以置信的悲伤时刻，作出了艰难的选择，
I was never able to meet my unsung hero. Her name was Sarah Ivy. And I know from speaking with her husband that she was a mother and a wife, and at this point she is now literally a part of me. I've been living with my new heart now for over a year. Believe it or not, my wife and I are now dreaming about taking that cross-country bicycle trip again. I'm shocked and I marvel at the fact that I'm still alive and I'm still with my family. And I think about Sarah and her family, who during those incredible times of grief, made the difficult choice to grant others
通过器官捐献赋予他人生命。我坚信，由于无数像莎拉·艾维这样的无名英雄，人性的心跳——共情、关怀和同情——依然充满生机与活力。安迪·戴维斯住在宾夕法尼亚州的印第安纳。本期《我无名的英雄》由 T-Mobile for Business 赞助播出。由 T-Mobile for Business 赞助播出。想要收听更多 Hidden Brain 的内容，包括你在其他地方听不到的想法和对话，请考虑加入我们的播客订阅 Hidden Brain Plus。它现在已在所有播客应用程序和设备上推出。你可以通过访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.co/hiddenbrain 加入。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们回头见。
life through organ donation. I truly believe that the heartbeat of humanity, empathy, care, and compassion, are alive and well because of countless unsung heroes like Sarah Ivy. Andy Davis lives in Indiana, Pennsylvania. This segment of My Unsung Hero was brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. For more Hidden Brain, including ideas and conversations you won't hear anywhere else, please consider joining our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus. It's now available across
你本集节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
all podcast apps and devices. You can join by going to support.hiddenbrain.org or apple.co. slash hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所有播客应用和设备。你可以通过访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.co/hiddenbrain 加入。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。这一集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。